hey guys dr. Berg here in this video
I'm going to talk about the iodine
estrogen connection if you're female you
need to definitely watch this because
women have way more estrogen than men
and we want to make sure we don't have
the bad estrogen that actually creates
cancer okay I'm going to show you the
mechanism here there's three types of
estrogen one is estrone then we have
estradiol and then we have estriol and
they all work differently but the
estradiol type of estrogen under certain
conditions can turn into the
cancer-causing estrogen called 16
hydroxyestrogen which is basically the
one that turns into cancer all right
but estriol is the one that is anti
cancer its cancer protective so it
really has to do with the ratios of
estrogen in your body and the
environment the health of your body okay
now just so happens that iodine is it's
an amazing mineral because it helps to
balance these ratios it increases
estriol to the estradiol so it's very
anti-cancer it's very cancer protective
it desensitizes the receptors for
estrogen basically it cleans them out
okay and so if you look at a good source
of iodine I always recommend seek help
now make sure if you're getting seek
help it's not just any regular sea kelp
that from any ocean because sometimes it
might be high in arsenic so you want to
get something from a very clean pristine
part of the world I use the Icelandic
sea kelp that's certified organic that's
a really clean place but it's very very
good for women in general and
specifically estrogen dominant women now
we also have the second thing that will
help balance these estrogens and that
would be all the cruciferous food right
so kale broccoli Brussels sprouts
cabbage bok choy arugula all those are
really really beneficial to help
desensitize the receptor to estrogen and
help these ratios come back so if I was
predisposed to
cancer I would be doing seek health and
cruciferous if you already had cancer
you definitely need to do this to
prevent it from coming back now as far
as men goes like interesting men as they
get older
they actually get higher estrogen so
they're getting gynecomastia which is
increased breast size they get prostate
problems because of high levels of
estrogen so this would be very
beneficial for them as well all right so
I just wanted to kind of show you the
relationship the connection and I will
see you in the next video